says this is a story that our i-team
first broke and vanessa murphy is
joining us now in studio with this
update vanessa denise and bryan a
longtime prosecutor refers to this case
as one of the worst whipping cases of
her career and yes i said whipping
investigators say a child was repeatedly
whipped by his parents with a cord and
belt he had to be hospitalized now
sources tell me those same parents who
admitted to doing this to their own son
want their kids back and i want to warn
you the images and details in this
report are graphic
this is
her
record for my overviews prosecutor dina
rennetti showed the court photos of a
boy with injuries bruises and scars all
over his body while his parents stood by
to learn what their sentence would be
last may ashley adams and david england
pleaded guilty to three felony counts of
child abuse after they were initially
charged with 19 counts judge beta yeager
handed them five years of probation and
now adams and england are trying to
regain custody of their now ten-year-old
son and five-year-old daughter hi is
this ashley adams we reached out to
adams in england by phone monday to try
to get their side of the story
our attempt to reach england was
unsuccessful so if you'd like to send me
a statement or do an interview to give
us your side of the story adams said she
didn't understand what the update is and
hung up here's what she previously said
in court i'm
not a bad person at all i love my kids
to death
and
i just wanted
to be a mom to them again and show them
how much i miss them how much i have
changed and learned along the
course of these two years
now the parents are trying to make their
case in family court sources tell the
i-team there was already a trial to
determine whether the children should be
reunited with their parents and then
judge stephanie charter took over the
case and is expected to make the
decision renee said these images are
warning signs something even worse could
have happened to the child who will live
with lifelong trauma this is ongoing
torture of this child
your honor
this
is the face of child abuse
this
is a face of a child in crisis
the trial to determine whether the
children will go back to their parents
is expected to continue later this week
the children were previously placed in
foster care when we learn what the judge
decides here we will let you know
[Music]